[Musique]
et bienvenue à tous bienvenue à tous en
ile de france
je ne peux pas commencer ce discours
sans dire un grand merci à christian
jacob pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce qu'il a choisi de vous réunir tous
en ile de france et notre région
aujourd'hui l'île de france
c'est une des régions qui est la plus
frappée par toutes les crises qui
traverse notre pays vous le savez nous
avons vécu au rythme des crises depuis
quatre ans cinq ans six ans il ya
d'abord eu le terrorisme islamiste
avec le bataclan il ya eu ensuite la
souffrance sociale des gilet jaune alors
on le sait pas mais les gilets jaunes
ont démarré dans le département de
christian jacob en seine et marne
parce qu'il n'ya pas de pire relégation
non en province et tenues parce qu'il
n'ya pas de pire relégation en réalité
que de vivre à 45 km de paris sans
transport sans médecin sans loisirs sans
sport sans culture et sans emploi on a
eu la crise des gels et j'en ai ensuite
on a eu la crise des cagoules noires les
cagoules noires c'est ceux qui ont pris
le relais vous savez c'est cet ultra
gauche qui s'est mis à tout casser tout
saccager des week-ends entiers au coeur
de nos villes et évidemment ils s'en
sont pris d'abord aux symboles de la
france les champs-elysées et puis
ensuite il ya ulcos vide et le co vide
eh bien nous l'avons subi de plein fouet
avec la région grand test nous avons été
la deuxième région la plus touchée et je
voudrais saluer philippe juvin qui est
ici qui vous le savez a été en première
ligne à la fois politique et sanitaire
pour lutter contre le co lead
et malheureusement re belote rebelote
nous sommes déjà une région rouge alors
que la rentrée n'a pas encore commencé
donc rebelote
et évidemment quand on dit chris kovy
dont 10 crise sanitaire mais on dit
aussi crise sociale et crise économique
et c'est la première fois sans doute
dans l'histoire de la france que la
région ile de france
certains d'entre vous diront peut-être
les riches les riches de l'île de france
sont les plus touchés le tourisme a
repris partout en france cet été sauf
dans les grandes villes
sauf à paris on a 20 à 30% de nos
restaurateurs qui sont menacés de
faillite et donc nous allons avoir
l'aéronautique
c'est une filière qui était la filière
de l'excellence de l'île de france
cessent pas cher jean-françois copé et
bien c'est une filière qui aujourd'hui
est très malade
donc vous voyez vous avez bien choisi
vous avez choisi une région dans
laquelle tout est en train de se tendre
et où tous les problèmes de la france
sont en résumé si vous avez fait un bon
choix parce que tu l'as dit christian
l'île de france c'est le symbole de nos
combats c'est le symbole d'un combat
gagné un combat gagné contre 17 ans de
gauche rassembler les socialistes les
verts les communistes les insoumis tous
ensemble ils ont géré l'île de france
avec un bilan calamiteux
il paraît qu'il va y avoir un échange
avec la salle je suis prête à parler des
verts et je suis prête à vous expliquer
comment depuis cinq ans avec une
majorité de très large rassemblement
avec vous les républicains avec aussi
les centristes il je peux pas les
oublier parce que si nous n'avions pas
fait ce très large rassemblement de la
droite et du centre on n'aurait pas
gagné l'île de france et on n'aurait pas
non plus gagner un certain nombre
d'autres régions
donc il faut ce rassemblement mais il
faut ce rassemblement pour tenir nos
engagements et pour tenir une ligne
politique qui est la nôtre celle de la
droite
et c'est quoi une politique de droite
c'est une ligne politique qui ne qui ne
transige pas avec la sécurité qui ne
transige pas avec les principes
républicains
j'ai auprès de moi le vice président des
républicains frédéric péchenard je peux
vous dire que nous ne transigeons pas
avec la sécurité on a fait une charte de
la laïcité j'ai appris que le président
de la république voulait la copier
trois ans après ma tant mieux si l'île
de france peut lui servir de modèles
mais je vous rassure la gauche non
seulement la combat à chaque séance du
conseil régional il propose un
amendement pour l'abroger mais en plus
ils l'ont déféré en justice
et ils se sont faits blackboulé donc il
ya une partie de la gauche qui a oublié
la laïcité la laïcité qui a oublié
jaurès qui a oublié la république il va
falloir le rappeler y compris à leurs
électeurs
alors oui l'île de france c'est notre
combat commun et c'est aussi une terre
où on a été rassemblé puissamment
rassembler mais je voudrais aussi te
remercier pour une troisième chose
christian c'est pour m'avoir invité
c'est pour m'avoir invité parce que
c'était pas une évidence mais c'est un
signe très puissant d'ouverture et ça te
ressemble et ça ressemble à ce que tu
veux faire des républicains
tu veux faire des républicains un parti
apaisé qui a des relations apaisées avec
toutes les partenaires vous savez je
suis une femme libre de ton de parole
j'ai mes défauts et mes qualités mais ce
que christian ans c'est parce que c'est
un grand politique c'est que quand la
droite s'élargit elle gagne et quand
elle serait très si elle perd et c'est
pas de lui c'est nicolas sarkozy
alors moi j'ai juste un tout petit mot
politique à vous dire avant qu'on fasse
savoir qu'on fasse le débat mais à mon
sens un atelier après bon bah vous
fassiez vous atelier un tout petit mot
politique avant un tout petit mot
politique non si nous étions pouvoir
nous ne ferions pas la politique d'
emmanuel macron et ça je tiens à le dire
et et et surtout pas sur le régalien et
surtout pas sur le régalien
non nous ne pensons pas qu'un délit ou
un crime c'est une incivilité et non les
français ne ressemble pas un sentiment
d'insécurité en ce moment ce qu'il
ressent c'est un sentiment d'impunité un
sentiment d'impunité des délinquants
parce qu'il ya un angle mort aujourd'hui
dans la politique du gouvernement
c'est la sanction la sanction immédiate
juste ferme proportionnée celle qui
permet de mettre hors d'état de nuire
tous ceux qui enfreignent nos lois donc
oui on a besoin aujourd'hui que l'état
se concentre sur le régalien on a besoin
d'une vraie politique de la droite avec
le centre et c'est cette politique là
que nous mènerions si nous étions
aujourd'hui au pouvoir je tiens à le
dire
j'ajoute que on peut être de droite on
peut être moderne
on peut être de droite on peut être
écologiste le bilan des verts à la
région
dernier de la classe en matière de
pollution de l'air dernier de la classe
en matière de bio dernier de la classe
en matière d'énergies renouvelables
pas de plan déchets et en revanche toute
l'idéologie de la décroissance
l'idéologie de la décroissance c'est
l'interdiction de la climatisation dans
les bus
l'interdiction du wifi dans les lycées
parce que les ondes on sait jamais et
l'interdiction évidemment de la
vidéoprotection dans les trains parce
que ça porte atteinte à la vie privée
donc ça fait cinq ans qu'on répare les
dégâts des verts donc si vous voulez
entendre parler d'écologie
allez voir les verts si vous voulez voir
faire de l'écologie
venez voir la droite et le centre en ile
de france
pareil pour le féminisme
pareil pour le féminisme vous assumiez
qu'on est aussi pour l'égalité femmes
hommes
mais notre féminisme il n'est pas à
géométrie variable et c'est pas un
féminisme qui défend le burqini sur les
plages au nom du droit à la différence
ni la burqa au nom de la liberté voilà
le féminisme votre féministe c'est un
universalisme
alors je vais conclure parce que je sens
que je moi aussi j'étais trop longue
mais comme dirait pierre bédier on est
toujours trop long je vais conclure mais
donc j'ai des défauts vous les
connaissez mais j'ai aussi une qualité
c'est que j'ai toujours fait confiance à
la jeunesse
j'ai toujours essayé de mettre le pied à
l'étrier aux jeunes et ça m'a porté
chance et je crois vraiment que un parti
qui se fonde sur ses jeunes
c'est un parti vivant c'est un parti qui
gagne
alors moi je vous le dis si vous êtes
ici vous savez que la république est à
genoux vous savez que la laïcité l'école
la sécurité la justice tout va mal dans
notre pays on fête les 150 ans de la
république
et pourtant la république n'a jamais été
aussi menacé et pourtant vous vous
engagez vous vous engagez pourquoi pas
ce que vous pensez que tout n'est pas
foutu parce que vous pensez que tout
n'est pas fini parce que vous savez que
la politique ça sert à quelque chose
et puis parce que vous êtes anti
conformiste que quand on est jeune et de
droite qu'on est anticonformiste et puis
parce que vous êtes courageux et parce
que vous vous laissez pas aveugler par
les discours qui vous disent qu'il ya
pas de place pour vous donc je vous le
dis votre engagement
il est profond il est sincère il est
puissant et vous n'êtes pas la remorque
du train vous devez être la locomotive
les jeunes dans un parti s'est pas fait
que pour mettre des tracts dans les
boîtes aux lettres et ramasser les
chaises à la fin des meetings les jeunes
dans les partis c'était pour aller se
faire élire c'est fait pour aller au
combat
y compris dans les terres difficiles et
c'est fait pour gagner
nous on a gagné sartre of 24 ans neuilly
sur marne en seine saint denis
on a gagné aubervilliers a déclaré mme
franklin un peu avant on avait gagné de
l'haÿ les roses avec vincent jean brun
avec trop barreda plus jeune député de
france on avait gagné juvisy on a othman
menace route est allé à trappes qui
maintenant est premier vice président de
la région ile de france et je n'oublie
pas les filles florence portelli agnès
evren que je salue alexandra du blanche
a mis la réserve toutes ces femmes qui
aussi se sont mises à faire de la
politique et les nolwenn le bouteur qui
a gagné langil la terre que le front
national voulait gagner communiste les
communistes ils ont pris cher en ile de
france en cette fois ci sont beaucoup
beaucoup perdu il a une dizaine de
villes ce qui va nous permettre j'espère
d'avoir des très bons résultats au
départemental je le dis aux franciliens
qui sont ici on repart pas sans avoir
gagné le val-de-marne et la
seine-saint-denis
sept départements sur huit c'est
l'objectif des prochaines départementale
alors chers amis bon atelier à tous et
surtout n'oubliez jamais vous êtes la
locomotive est pas la remorque
[Applaudissements]